[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
niedrigen abend zusammen basketball-em
und fußball champions league heute abend
was steht da genau an katja
im viertelfinale gegen topfavorit
griechenland und dann noch der knaller
im fussball bayern gegen barcelona ja
freuen wir uns später mehr dazu jetzt
noch gemeinsam der blick auf die anderen
themen
teure energie strauchelnde unternehmen
der arbeitgeber präsident rechnet mit
einer rezession und fordert hilfen der
kanzler stellt sie in aussicht
lebenslang nach tankstellen mord weil er
keine corona maske tragen wollte
erschoss ein mann den kassierer und muss
dafür mindestens 15 jahre in haft
und revolutionär des kinos der regisseur
jean luc godard dessen filme wie außer
atem magisch mit allen regeln brachen
stirbt mit 91 jahren
wohl selten fand ein deutscher
arbeitgebertag in wirtschaftlich so
angespannten zeiten statt unternehmen
machen sich große sorgen um
energiepreise und sicherheit um
inflation oder eklatanten
fachkräftemangel und das ließ der
verbandspräsident den anwesenden kanzler
und die zuständigen minister auch wissen
andreas huppert fast reaktionen und
forderungen zusammen beginnt zunächst
aber mit einem beispiel
metallfolien extra dünnen zur
herstellung von batterien und elektronen
die schlenk ag mittelfränkischen
baiersdorf produziert und vertreibt sie
weltweit die herstellung ist extrem
energieintensiv und der strom
hierzulande längst zum preistreiber
geworden ist werden deutsche produkte
auf dem weltmarkt teuer
die deutlich höheren energiekosten
führen dazu dass die materialien aus
denen viele produkte produziert werden
die für die energiewende notwendig sind
so teuer werden dass sie in deutschland
nicht mehr hergestellt werden und dass
sich dann ganze lieferketten ins ausland
verlagern
explodierender energiepreise und
absatzverluste schweben wie ein
damoklesschwert über dem arbeitgebertag
der appell an die politik wir brauchen
hilfen unsere wirtschaft droht die
schwerste krise seit beginn der
bundesrepublik und deshalb ist es jetzt
an der politik ihr handeln zu ändern die
ursachenbekämpfung anzugehen und sich
nicht nur mit der symptombekämpfung
aufzuhalten der kanzler verweist in
seiner rede auf die bereits beschlossene
entlastungspaket auch für die wirtschaft
95 milliarden euro eine riesige
dimension um für eine entlastung zu
sorgen bei den bürgern und bürgern bei
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmern aber
eben auch bei der deutschen wirtschaft
forderungen der arbeitgeber nach
günstigem strom das versteht der
wirtschaftsminister doch alle vorschläge
sind teuer wenn sie sagen schafft die
stromsteuer abschafft die netzentgelte
ab würde ich als energie und ich würde
auch sagen als klimaschutzminister sagen
gerne nur kostet das gleich wieder zehn
milliarden strom günstig machen kostet
geld und so wartet die deutsche
wirtschaft weiter vorschläge der politik
die energiepreise in deutschland zu
sehen
also der wirtschaftsminister kündigt
weitere hilfen für unternehmen an in
welcher höhe noch unklar für
privatverbraucher hat die
bundesregierung zwar auch umfassende
hilfspakete auf den weg gebracht ob die
aber die extremen belastungen beim
gaspreis ausgleichen darf man bezweifeln
schon jetzt flattern fielen die neu
kalkulierten und exorbitant gestiegenen
abschlags rechnungen ins haus stefanie
gareis berichtet
es wird gerechnet vielerorts in
deutschland auch bei familie becker im
saarland ab erster oktober steigen auch
ihre abschläge für gas das macht sich in
der haushaltskasse bemerkbar
134 euro obendrauf für die beckers als
doppelverdiener ist das noch zu stemmen
doch je nach anbieter und region können
es mal schnell 100 euro mehr sein für
manchen ist das nicht mehr zu leisten
nur ein verdienst muss man schon schauen
dass mister weitergeben
genau vor einem jahr lag der
durchschnittliche preis pro
kilowattstunde bei etwa 5,9 cent heute
ist es rund sechsmal so hoch seit anfang
des monats fallen die preise wieder
naja die spekulanten gehen jetzt langsam
aus dem markt raus die haben in den
letzten wochen und monaten damit
gerechnet dass das gas knapp wird und
jetzt stellen sie fest die gasspeicher
zum winter sind doch ganz gut gefühlt
viel geld hat der bund dafür bezahlt
laut finanzminister lindner soll das den
bürgern noch in diesem winter zu gute
kommen diese milliarden euro die
eingesetzt worden sind um die
gasspeicher zu befüllen haben natürlich
auch den marktpreis in deutschland
anziehen lassen
aber wir werden auch aus speichern und
das wieder in den markt zurückgeben und
gassen natürlich beruhigungs signale in
den markt wenn angebot und nachfrage
sich wieder annähern sinken auch die
preise so die hoffnung für familie
becker heißt es vorerst aber weiter das
geld zusammenhalten
ja nicht nur energie ist deutlich teurer
geworden das statistische bundesamt
bestätigte im august stieg die inflation
auf 7,9 prozent aber nicht überall
schlägt die preissteigerung im selben
maße zu in unserer app finden sie eine
analyse was besonders teuer wurde und
was im august sogar günstiger war
zum ersten mal seit wochen hat
bundeskanzler scholz mit dem russischen
präsidenten putin telefoniert 90 minuten
lang und natürlich ging es vor allem um
den russischen krieg in der ukraine
scholz habe laut regierungssprecher
darauf gedrungen dass es so schnell wie
möglich zu einer diplomatischen lösung
kommen solle die forderungen von scholz
ein waffenstillstand vollständiger
rückzug der russischen truppen und
achtung der ukrainischen souveränität in
der ukraine melden die behörden dass die
russischen truppen weiter auf dem
rückzug sein im osten haben sie demnach
jetzt auch erste ortschaften in der
region luhansk verlassen laut präsident
zielinski hat die ukrainische armee
inzwischen mehr als 6000
quadratkilometer besetztes gebiet
zurückerobert unter anderem rund um
krakau bei ihrem rückzug hat die
russische armee offenbar zahlreiche
panzer zurückgelassen ukrainische
soldaten entfernen vielerorts zeichen
der besatzung
katrin eigendorf ist für uns ein tag
rief katrin wie erlebst du die jüngsten
entwicklungen den vormarsch
beziehungsweise den rückzug
ja wir hatten heute das erste mal
gelegenheit in ballack leer einer der
befreiten städte mit menschen zu
sprechen und uns die lage vor ort
anzuschauen das ukrainische militär hat
das bislang nicht erlaubt und was wir da
erlebt haben hat ein bild ergeben dass
eigentlich nicht mit dem übereinstimmt
was wladimir putin behauptet dass die
armee sich da re gruppiert wir haben
gesehen dass dort die russen munition
hinterlassen haben dass sie dort auch
panzer hinterlassen haben dort wurden
teilweise schwere militärfahrzeuge von
den ukrainern abgeschleppt an uns vorbei
und wir hatten auch gelegenheit damit
den einwohnern zu sprechen die ja sechs
monate unter russischer besatzung gelebt
haben viele waren noch immer
traumatisiert manche haben geweint vor
freude dass sie jetzt endlich wieder in
freiheit leben und was sie uns erzählt
haben war eigentlich übereinstimmen dass
die russischen soldaten von einem moment
auf den anderen die stadt verlassen
haben einfach alles liegenlassen haben
viele haben das natürlich nicht selbst
miterlebt sondern haben sich in ihren
häusern verschanzt aber im prinzip
hatten sie gesagt es wurde gar nicht so
viel gekämpft in der stadt sondern die
russischen soldaten sind geflohen von
einem moment auf den anderen sie haben
viele häuser geplündert teilweise auch
autos von den menschen mitgenommen aber
das wirkt schon jetzt nicht nach einem
geordneten
zug was wir da erlebt haben was die
menschen uns erzählt haben live aus
katrin eigendorf vielen dank und es gibt
noch einen weiteren konflikt in dem
russland indirekt eine rolle spielt und
zwar im südkaukasus bei schweren kämpfen
zwischen armenien und aserbaidschan sind
auf armenischer seite nach offiziellen
angaben mindestens 49 soldaten getötet
worden auch aserbaidschan meldet tote
bei angriff mehrere stellungen im
nachbarland an beide seiten geben sich
gegenseitig die schuld an der neuen
eskalation der konflikt dauert seit
jahrzehnten an weil beide staaten
ansprüche auf die region berg karabach
erheben wir sprechen mit filme gar in
moskau führte welche rolle spielt
russland in diesem konflikt
in russland ist die schutzmacht von
armenien reagiert als diese aber gerade
ziemlich zögerlich während die türkei
sich heute sofort an die seite von
aserbaidschan gestellt hat hat der kreml
beide seiten zur besonnenheit aufgerufen
in dem konflikt oder dem krieg vor zwei
jahren da hatte aserbaidschan große
teile von berg karabach erobert aber
eben nicht das gesamte gebiet dass das
land für sich beansprucht und aus der
sicht von aliev dem präsidenten da
könnte der moment jetzt ganz günstig
sein das nachzuholen allerdings das
territorium auf dem heute nacht gekämpft
wurde das liegt ganz eindeutig auf
armenischen staatsterritorium also eben
nicht in dem umstrittenen berg karabach
und das liegt jenseits der linie entlang
derer der konflikt damals vor zwei
jahren eingefroren wurde eine linie die
eigentlich bewacht werden sollte von
russischen friedenstruppen jetzt ist das
russische militär aber ja gerade in der
ukraine sehr gefordert und für moskau
kommt also diese eskalation im kaukasus
jetzt zur unzeit
auch weil der präsident sich hier
ungewöhnlicherweise innenpolitischer
kritik ausgesetzt sieht eine neue front
kann wladimir putin ganz sicher nicht
gebrauchen komplexe gemengelage vielen
dank für die einordnung nach moskau
zurück nach deutschland der deutsche
städtetag fordert die bundesregierung
auf einen neuen flüchtlings gipfel
einzuberufen hintergrund sind engpässe
bei der unterbringung und auch dass sich
inzwischen
mehr als die hälfte der bundesländer für
die flüchtlingsaufnahme haben sperren
lassen zum winter hin dürfte sich die
situation deswegen weiter verschärfen
jutta sonne wald berichtet anna svitlana
und alexej wissen um ihr glück nicht nur
dass sie in deutschland zuflucht
gefunden haben vor dem krieg in ihrer
heimat der ukraine
zudem haben sie in münchen inzwischen
ein eigenes dach über dem kopf
es war für mich ein wenig einfacher da
ich alleine bin für familien ist es viel
schwieriger eine große wohnung zu finden
in der kirchlichen einrichtung in der
wir anfangs gelebt haben sind noch fünf
familien untergebracht die immer noch
keine eigene wohnung haben
etwa eine million geflüchtete sind seit
ausbruch des krieges in der ukraine vor
etwas über einem halben jahr nach
deutschland geflohen wie viele von ihnen
noch hier sind können die behörden nicht
sagen da sie nicht wissen wer zurück
oder weiter gereist ist der städtetag
rechnet mit mehr flüchtlingen im winter
wir wollen wieder am tisch sitzen bund
länder und kommunen wir wollen unsere
aufgaben tun aber wir müssen einen
flüchtlings gipfel durchführen um uns
vorzubereiten auf diese lage die auf uns
zu tauschen in einigen kommunen werden
wieder turnheim zu schlafstätten
umfunktioniert da die zahl der
geflüchteten aus anderen ländern wie
syrien und afghanistan schon jetzt
steigt sollte nicht bald mehr wohnraum
geschaffen werden müssten in solchen
notunterkünften auch ukrainische
kriegsflüchtlinge untergebracht werden
bisher kamen viele privat unter doch
eine dauerlösung ist das nicht zu anfang
des krieges haben wir gesagt leute viele
kommen jetzt unter und die kommunen
müssen aber gucken dass sie wohnraum zur
verfügung stellen weil das geht nicht
lange gut das kennen wir aus den balkan
kriegen da hatten wir die gleiche
situation ja da ist nicht adäquat
reagiert worden anna alexej und svetlana
nehmen an einem deutsch- und
integrationskurse in münchen teil sie
sind heilfroh dass für sie das thema
wohnungssuche schon abgehakt ist
ja zu einem bemerkenswerten
grundsatzurteil das für die arbeitswelt
weitreichende folgen haben dürfte in
deutschland ist es in zukunft pflicht
die arbeitszeiten zu erfassen so hat das
bundesarbeitsgericht entschieden und
folgt damit einem europäischen urteil
bislang mussten nach dem deutschen
arbeitsgesetz nur überstunden und
sonntagsarbeit dokumentiert werden
weil er einen kunden aufforderte eine
corona maske aufzusetzen wurde ein
20-jähriger tankstellen mitarbeiter
erschossen vor ungefähr einem jahr
ereignete sich dieses kaltblütige
verbrechen entsetzen deutschlandweit
heute nach fünf monaten prozess das
urteil lebenslang für den
rechtsradikalen täter das gericht
spricht von einer heimtückischen tat aus
niederen beweggründen mehr von christel
happ
man sieht ihr an was sie durch leidet es
ist ihr sohn der erschossen wurde von
diesem mann mario m fast regungslos
vernimmt der das urteil der richter
lebenslänglich
vor fast einem jahr an dieser tankstelle
in idar oberstein der 20 jährige alex w
steht abends an der kasse die
überwachungskamera zeigt den täter ohne
maske er will bier kaufen doch alex beh
verweist ihn mehrfach auf die masten
pflicht der mann geht kommt später aber
zurück er ist alkoholisiert schießt dem
jungen mann ins gesicht
mario inhaber ein exempel statuieren
wollen gegen den staat gegen die korona
maßnahmen erklärten die richter eine
besondere schwere der schuld stellten
sie aber nicht fest wir sind zufrieden
mit dem urteil es war aus sicht der
staatsanwaltschaft wichtig dass das
gericht diese tat als mord verurteilt
die verteidigung hatte auf totschlag
plädiert die schuldfähigkeit des täters
sei eingeschränkt gewesen
wesentlich war natürlich für die
verteidigung dass das gericht uns
gefolgt ist und nicht von einer
besonderen schutz schwere ausgegangen
ist das ermöglicht dem angeklagt nach 15
jahren eine bedingte entlassung
dann spricht sie die mutter 15 jahre für
ein menschenleben
egal wie das urteil ausgegangen wäre es
hätte ja nichts daran geändert was
passiert ist und welcher mensch verloren
gegangen ist es bringt ja nie wieder
mein kind zurück ende eines prozesses
doch ihr schmerz wird bleiben
fünf tage nach dem tod der queen haben
in der schottischen hauptstadt edinburgh
noch einmal tausende abschied von ihrer
verstorbenen königin genommen am abend
bringt ein flugzeug der royal airforce
den sack nach london wo schon die
vorbereitungen für das staatsbegräbnis
laufen könig charles besuchte die
nordirische hauptstadt belfast dort
sprachen ihm die menschen ihr beileid
aus viele in nordirland stehen dem
königshaus eher kritisch gegenüber
wir verlieren einen nationalen schatz
sagt der französische präsident makro
über star regisseur jean luc godard der
im alter von 91 jahren gestorben ist
einer der einflussreichsten filmemacher
der in den 1960 er jahren bilder
schnitte und ästhetik innovativ
revolutionierte und somit auch das
gesamte kino über den tod von jean luc
godard dort
verwahrten jean luc godards durchbruch
als regisseur radikale schnitte radikale
geschichte führte hatte kino
keine es kein leben gibt muss man sich
auch keinen technischen regeln und
anarchie und kann für sich selbst einen
weg finden bilder wie das leben zu
machen nicht
da stellt das kino auf den kopf keine
geschichten sondern bilder erstmals mit
handkamera ohne künstliches licht
die duh will war des französischen films
ein kino revolutionär einen radikalen
cup akteur der im mai 1968 und abbruch
der filmfestspiele von cannes verzinkt
radikal linksradikal vorreiter gut da
geht von filme auf video und bleibt bei
der oft rätselhaften kunst seiner bilder
sah
ich habe ich nicht ganz verstanden
was heißt schon verstehen das ist nicht
schlimm man versteht nicht unbedingt
immer alles sofort vor dem verstehen
muss man erst einmal etwas in sich
aufnehmen
auch im digitalen zeitalter blieb gut da
sich treu und gilt die erste handy
pressekonferenz in cannes ab kino
pionier mit immer neuen formen
wir machen ohne handy beim sport weiter
fußball champions league und alle
schauten auf eine person hatte ja alle
blicken auf robert lewandowski der ja
bekanntermaßen seit dieser saison nicht
mehr für die bayern erfolgreich auf
torejagd geht sondern für den fc
barcelona der ist heute abend zu gast
auf dem rasen inklusive des topstürmers
natürlich wer soll ihn stoppen robert
lewandowski scheint sich wohlzufühlen
bei barca er zaubert weiter unaufhaltsam
traf in seinen ersten sechs spielen
bereits neumann finsterling er ist ein
teamplayer er kann den raum lesen und
hat ein starkes pressing ich bin
begeistert von ihm er ist ein anführer
und ein fantastischer neuzugang ist
fantastisch lewandowskis rückkehr in die
allianz arena ist durchaus brisant denn
die bayern wollten den 34 jährigen und
seine tore eigentlich behalten der plan
nun den weltfußballer gar nicht erst ins
spiel kommen lassen ja er ist
wahrscheinlich der torgefährlichste
spieler im kader aber wenn er keine
bälle kriegt dann ist auch schwer von
torge für den spieler tore zu machen
tore machen sollten dagegen die bayern
zuletzt fehlte jedoch die effizienz
viele chancen zwar aber wenig treffer
drei unentschieden in der bundesliga
zeigen es hakt
alles zu diesem zweiten spieltag morgen
an von 23 15 an hier im zdf-sportstudio
champions league und bereits heute abend
spielt die deutsche basketball
nationalmannschaft im em viertelfinale
gegen griechenland das ganze in berlin
wo einige bangen ob deutschlands
shootingstar franz wagner trotz jetzt
verstauchten knöchel wieder fit sein
wird
nba-profi franz wagner beim heutigen
abschlusstraining der fuß scheint in
ordnung zu sein dennoch bleibt sein
einsatz bis zum beginn des spiels oft
bundestrainer gordon herbert hofft auf
den 21-jährigen für die partie gegen
favorit griechenland mit aber nicht nur
mit superstar anpumpen
sie sind ein sehr talentiertes team vom
ersten bis zum 12 es geht nicht nur
eine große aufgabe für das dbb team aber
das halbfinale bei der heim-em wind und
damit die chance auf die erhoffte
medaille
und das wäre die erste seit 17 jahren
dankeschön katja wie das wetter morgen
wird das verrät ihnen gleich denn terry
die nachrichten des tages ordnet dann ab
21 45 anne gellinek im heute-journal ein
morgen hier an dieser stelle barbara
hahlweg danke fürs interesse und noch
einen entspannten abend für sie
[Musik]
schon gute und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter 30 grad gab es heute im südwesten
deutschlands so war es die luftmasse wir
uns von süden her erreicht und sehr
feuchte und stößt auf die kühle
luftmassen aus dem norden diese
luftmassengrenze die sich dadurch aus
bildet die ist ziemlich stationär und so
gibt es relativ viel regen bereits in
der nacht regnet es südlich im südlichen
nordrhein-westfalen in der mitte bis
nach osten und in den südwesten auch
hier gewitter sonst ist es trocken und
das bei tiefsten temperaturen von neun
grad in der norddeutschen tiefebene und
20 grad tropische nacht im südwesten
deutschlands und morgen am vormittag
viel regen in der mitte und auch im
süden dann zum nachmittag mit gewittern
durchsetzt und die regenmengen liegen
bei 20 bis 50 liter auf den quadratmeter
bei gewittern kommt noch mehr obendrauf
im norden ist es dagegen trocken
temperaturen 16 grad unter dem regen
noch mal 25 bis 26 grad ganz im süden
noch mal richtig warm ja die nächsten
tage donnerstag rutschen regen und
gewitter weiter in den süden bei 16 bis
22 grad und auch danach bleibt es
ziemlich wechselhaft ein schöner abend